hey this is presh talwalker
start with the circle whose radius
length is equal to 12. in each
semi-circle inscribe a circle that
passes through the center of the large
Circle
Let each of these circles have radius
length equal to B
then inscribe a circle that's tangent to
these two circles and the large Circle
and let its radius length be equal to a
finally inscribe a circle in the
semi-circle that's tangent to the
diameter tangent to the large Circle and
tangent to the circle with radius length
equal to B
let this radius length be equal to C the
question is what is a plus b plus c
equal to
I think David for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
what's fun about this problem is the
three radius lengths are an increasing
order of difficulty to calculate them
let's start with the radius length B
construct a diameter of this circle
which has length equal to 2B this is
exactly a radius of the large Circle so
2B is equal to 12 which means B is equal
to 6.
starts out easy enough
now let's calculate the value of a
construct the following right triangle
where one leg is equal to B
the hypotenuse is equal to the sum of
the radii so its length will be a plus b
what's the length of the other leg of
this right triangle
we know that this length is equal to a
and a radius of the large circle is
equal to 12. so the other leg will have
length equal to 12 minus a
since we have a right triangle we have
the square of a plus b is equal to B
squared plus the square of 12 minus a
substituting in that b is equal to 6 we
can simplify this equation and we can
work out that a is going to be equal to
4.
so now let's work out the value of C
we will first construct the following
radius of the large Circle
this will have length equal to 12.
next construct this radius which has
length equal to C
now we have a right triangle here where
one leg is equal to C the length of the
hypotenuse will be the length of the
radius of the large Circle minus the
length of the radius of the small circle
so its length will be equal to 12 minus
C
but the length of the other leg be equal
to X
now let's solve for x squared since we
have a right triangle x squared is equal
to the square of 12 minus C minus c
squared we can simplify this equation to
get x squared is equal to 144 minus 24c
now let's construct the following right
triangle
one leg will be equal to X the other leg
will be the difference in the lengths of
the radii so it will be equal to B minus
C the hypotenuse will be the sum of the
radii lengths so it will be equal to B
plus c
now let's solve for x squared in this
right triangle we have x squared is
equal to the square of B plus C minus
the square of B minus C
we can simplify this equation to get x
squared is equal to four BC
now we can substitute in that b is equal
to 6.
so if x squared is equal to 24c so we
can now focus on these two equations and
we can set them equal to each other
so if 24c is equal to 144 minus 24c
simplifying will give that c is equal to
3. so we solve for the values of a b and
c and this gives that a plus b plus C is
equal to four plus six plus three and
that gives the answer of 13.
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world problems one video at a
time